kamel a retrouvé ses camarades du
collège victor hugo un pansement sur sa
tempe témoigne de l'incident hier vers
15h30 il sortait de cours quand il a été
la cible de tirs à proximité de
l'établissement
c'est avec deux copines on est en train
de marcher et on en parlait et
événements en fait j'ai reçu deux balles
et j'étais blessé l'arme serait une
carabine à plombs légèrement blessés les
deux collégiens ont été pris en charge
médicalement avant de pouvoir reprendre
les cours ce mardi matin un retour à la
normale qui rassure élèves et parents
mais j'ai eu peur et j'ai eu peur pour
les miens mais choqué que quelqu'un
s'est fait toujours rien j'ai vu la
police
emmener quelqu'un du coup jeudi les plus
là je pense qu'on fiche c'est vrai que
j'étais choquée que ça puisse arriver
ici surtout danse voilà qui est assez
paisible donc
cela fait bizarre l'auteur des faits
serait un adolescent qui aurait tiré
depuis une maison voisine mais sans lien
a priori avec le collège la seule chose
que je puisse dire c'est
qu'effectivement il n'a aucun lien avec
l'établissement scolaire
aucun lien avec des élèves de cet
établissement
ce mardi les courses sont déroulées sans
encombre les forces de l'ordre ont
renforcé leur présence aux abords du
collège et une cellule d'écouté a été
mise en place pour les élèves qui en
auraient besoin
on se fédèrent et on met en place les
mesures nécessaires pour sécuriser les
élèves pour rassurer les membres de la
communauté éducative les élèves les
familles les professionnels
le jeune homme suspecté a été placé en
garde à vue et pourraient être mises en
examen dans la soirée jeux stupides ou
volonté de nuire l' enquête devra faire
la lumière sur ses motivations mais son
geste pourrait lui valoir une lourde
sanction